PAVEL BUCHNEVICH
>> Eddie: BUCHNEVICH HAS TO
SHOOT THAT ZIBANEJAD WITH
enny:.
REBOUND, SCORE.
ALEXEX IT.
PUTS IT ON THE ICE AND BURIES IT
TO THE BACK OF THE
LAFRENIERE.
>> Eddie: GOOD PLAY BY O'REILLY
TO SHUT THAT PLAY OFF.
>> Eddie: GOOD STICK BY KREIDER.
NO SHOTS ON THE POWER PLAY FOR
ST. LOUIS..
>> Eddie: LOOKED LIKE IT WOULD
BE A HECK OF
HERE'S BARBASHEV.
NOW THOMAS
MILLER HAD IT TAKEN E THOUGHT P
GOING TO FIRE IT, JONESY, AND HE
WAS OFF HI IN FRONT -- OH, THE
FININIDON
SAAD.
>> Keith: OUTSTANDING PASS.
EDZO, IT SE BLUES GAIN CONTROL
PUCK.
OUTLET PASS FOR
AND BARBASHEV JUST
SHOT, SCORE, PERRON!
3-2, ST. LOUISAT FEED.
HOW MANY TIMES PUCK, HE'S
OUT OF THE BLU PASS
FROM STROME.
KREIDER SETTING UP IN EZE THAT
HEAVY ONE-TIME
PANARIN, 15 SECONDS REMAINING ON
THE PENALTY -- SCORET BE AFRAIDT
THE PUCK TO THE NET,
ARTEMI PANARIN SHOOTS, SCORES.Y
WITH PANARIN PICKING UP THAT
GO